how are you i'm good i'm doing good i'm
still beaming from all of the the
amazing things that have been happening
so
i'm still trying to keep it together
no don't keep it together get excited
this is a joyous time right i mean this
song feels like pure joy it's love it's
celebration
um
just what made you say i have to release
this single particularly
so me verdin
john and neal these are all the guys who
took part in creating this right yes
um
we were literally in quarantine at this
time
and
covid was running rampantly uh we had so
much that we were dealing with when it
came to um injustices in the world with
the movement that was happening
we were like we wanted this to really be
released in a time where people can
really feel it so it can amp them up
even more
and
it didn't get to happen at that time so
we were like darn it you know we got a
little nervous well not we i got a
little nervous they were totally fine
or like rocks for me um
and then we
worked on it a little bit more i went
back into the studio i was like hey neil
he's the producer
he literally was like i want to
i told him i wanted to do a little bit
more with the song
a week afterwards we started rolling out
and started releasing the song and the
rest is history and i wanted to get the
song out because
i wanted love to be shown again we have
gone through so much stuff and
why not have a song out where we can
just dance to and be happy and feel
joyous you know
yeah love is when
great things happen everything done in
love is where the good things are i mean
there would be um i imagine a lot of
feelings going into studio to shoot
something like this or to to get
something going like this
how nervous were you going into the
studio
um believe it or not i wasn't that
nervous girl i had been ready to get
into the studio i was like i need to i
need to start writing music again i need
to get in the studio and just test it
out again you know and
me and a couple of verdeen's friends and
a couple of my close colleagues we were
all working together at the time and
it just happened so quickly i mean are
we recorded in a day we recorded the
whole song in a day
wow
but i think that was all of us we were
and we still are we're hungry and we
love music so i was just like let's make
it happen soon and we all went in there
and it was just the rest is history
oh i love that no listen when you're
recording music or you're looking at a
script who is your person that you go to
to be like
you know you have your own thoughts and
your feelings about it but to get
outside of yourself who's your person
that you go to and be like what do you
think of this
i know how i'm feeling but could you
give me some outside perspective who's
your person
oh man i mean
i usually
this sounds crazy enough i'll either
call some of my friends i'll text some
of my friends but the the main person i
go to is my boyfriend i'm like okay so
you're a writer you know what this means
he's a writer so i'm just like you know
this can you read this down for me can
you get this structure for me like when
it comes to a script and
both like we just mesh well we're really
good like comrades and he helps me out a
lot you know and
he's just really great he's really
really really great so he's the person
that i go to aside from my mom like my
family is my hugest
supporter so i just i piggy like not
piggyback excuse me those are the wrong
words but you know i take little pieces
and bits from them when i can
so what was all of their your
boyfriend's reaction your mom what was
their reaction to the single when they
heard it
well
my my boyfriend's reaction he was
actually on the shoot actually he was
there watching everything go down and i
was like come on daddy we gotta go to
this shoe and he was like
so he came with me and
he loved it he was recording the whole
time my mom was so excited you know she
was dancing to the song sometimes she
didn't even listen to the song to watch
the video because she was listening so
much and just my family they they
showered me with so much love with so
much love for it so i i felt good about
it
i love that you make it look so
incredibly easy in the music video um
but i saw you mastering the moves you
know on what you posted on social media
um what was it like in rehearsal getting
ready for this
well shirley quigley she's an amazing
choreographer uh and
she really like whipped me into shape
and it was so sweet and it was so good
she's such a beautiful
beautiful spirit her spirit is amazing
and we just messed so well and i
remember we had a day before um the
shoot
eight hour uh day
me and the girls and we just like worked
together that was because what me and
charlene had built and what me and the
girls the dancers have built so it was a
great process and i'm still thankful for
them because sometimes when i was even
slipping they sent me affirmations all
the time especially charlene she was
like oh you got this don't worry about
it don't think about it i'm such a
perfectionist and she just she lifted me
up she's good good people so yeah great
great great group of people
it's so good to be surrounded by by
people like that and you're in such a
beautiful stage of your life and your
career and you have so much to say and
can make such a big difference in this
world
how does that make you feel
it makes me feel good it makes me feel
like all of my dreams were heard i feel
like the universe and listened to me
when i prayed for it and it's coming
exactly how i actually prayed for it and
it does
actually make me think like oh snap you
know there is something bigger but um
yeah i just i'm thankful for every
single last thing that i've gotten and
i'm not gonna ever i'm i'm never gonna
lose my footing on the ground because i
have such a sturdy foundation around me
and
i'm just thankful i'm thankful because
none of this stuff could have ever
happened not for a girl like me and
you know now i get a chance to be the
example for the girls all around the
world like they get to all the girls
around the world not just trans girls
just sis girls but both and
that makes me happy and
now people will see that we can move
through the world
like any other human being on this earth
simply by the examples that are given to
them so that's right
yeah
i love that where your mind goes your
body grows it all grows and goes
together right
definitely
you have really made history first
transgendered actress to be nominated
for an emmy in a league category i mean
you were in the history books what is
that feeling
oh it's it's an insane feeling to
it's an insane feeling it's a
wonderfully insane feeling
yeah know that you're making history and
you never thought you were gonna make
history because discrimination is thrown
at you you know before this even happens
and then it just changes at the drop of
a dime so i'm
i'm a bit
uh dreamy eyed i still like want to be
pinched a little bit i asked my mom like
mommy is this real like i don't
you know what she's like it's real baby
be happy choose the moments when you
have to be happy
and i really appreciate that from her
because it just instilled in me that i
have to enjoy it i'm such a
perfectionist that i'm like no because
the people need this and this is what
the world needs like what about you
and i'm like well i can't think about
that just yet and i'm just like no you
have to because you have to be able to
give yourself to the people you have to
save for yourself to give to the people
so it's been hard to receive all of it
and i'm just like
amazingly overwhelmed
well you can't pour from an empty bucket
right you fill yours first you fill
another one and then you give from the
second one your mom like she knows the
thing your mom sounds incredible she's
amazing has she always been that
insightful that rock that that love for
you
since you were little yes she's been
there since day one like the love has
never stopped it has been nothing but
overflowing and
i'm so appreciative of that because
that's why i'm able to emit the love
that i've received i'm able to give it
to other people because i got the right
kind of love you know and not saying
that people didn't get the wrong kind of
love i just know but
yeah as a trans girl a lot of girls
don't get that you know because of what
the world
has created us to be and it's just not
true
yeah yeah your mom sounds incredible hi
mom
okay emmy knight
are you nervous are you excited do you
have a speech written what did you get
outfit
oh my god there's so many questions um
i don't have a speech ready i i'm just
thankful i'm i'm also leaving it to the
universe i'm like whatever the outcome
may be it is um maybe i'll write a
speech i was thinking about it yesterday
i don't know uh the dress
oh i i can't say but i do have it and
i'm pairing up with him
yes amazing designer i'm just really
excited about
her her and
what she represents she's amazing so
this is exciting i love it yes write a
speech do it do it twitter um you've
mentioned your boyfriend a couple of
times can you share with us how you met
and how you knew this guy was special
well
believe it or not i met this amazing man
through instagram and i never thought
that that would happen but that's now a
regular thing now which i
didn't know i you know i had a bit of
traditionalism in my life so
like make sure you meet your friend of
your cousin of your brother's sister
and i was like that's how it happened
that doesn't sound like i can trust them
a little bit more yeah yeah
i met this man on instagram and
we facetimed millions of times and then
we found a time to meet and then i think
we fell completely over each other when
we met and then we had a second date and
then now two years down the line we're
together and i'm just really thankful
for him and i can actually finally
say
nationally publicly i'm in love with
this man i appreciate him for what he
gives to me he makes me feel so good i
love the love that he gives me and i had
a a mindset of what men were like and i
still have a mindset of how men can be
you know what i mean but it can be but
when you have a good one i mean
right it changes
it changes the dynamic a little bit and
i like that so he's great
well and he's lucky to have you
obviously is such a strong woman and so
talented and beautiful i mean i think he
hit the jackpot that's what i would say
that's what i would say so love right
back for sure
thank you um you had such a beautiful
chemistry with billy porter has that
chemistry sort of
you know continued off-screen
yeah i mean i just spoke to billy
a couple of days ago and you know we
still have that that beautiful poor he's
working with a lovely actress now and um
you know he's like hey you got a call
you got to talk to her you know what i
mean we still talk and we still have a
great report and i think it was just
beautiful that's working on set i've
known him for a long time too billy is
everything
he is a fairy godmother in the new
version of cinderella which is
incredible
you saw
you saw it i well i didn't i didn't get
a chance to see it well no no i did get
a chance to see a sneak before
anyone got the chance because he showed
me why we were on post but i didn't get
to get a chance to see the whole thing
okay so what do you think of him as a
fairy godmother i think it's sickening
and the scene that i got to see
it was
spectacular and billy
slayed those people and i'm just i'm
here for it i love what he brings to the
table for the television screen
amazing okay now i know we have to go i
think my minutes are down here but next
number for you
i know this is good i like it i've got
so much to more ask you okay so tick
tick boom with andrew garfield talk a
little bit about that and what's it like
to see him in that role
he's amazing i mean i've been watching
andrew for a while though ever since he
like
came out in spider-man like he's a
really great actor and working with him
was great working with robin d jesus was
amazing um lyndon well he's a huge huge
follower of jonathan larson and jonathan
larson is a huge
just a huge icon to me and a lot of
people who are part of the work that
he's done and that he's created so it
was a blessing to be a part of this
movie honestly because it's for jonathan
and everybody has done it for jonathan
so yeah yes and do you think lynn could
be our next oscar-winning director i
surely do baby i surely do see mr
lin-manuel i see him he's an amazing
director so i definitely see it coming
his way okay well listen if you need
anyone to shop with for your oscar
dresses your emmy dresses your golden
globes i will come i will hold your
purse i'll give you an honest opinion
i'm just saying just a good you know
just a good girl on the side not not
holding a purse you you you're you got
to hold your person like swinging with
you you know you're cute you're real
cute you gotta you know just be gonna be
sitting alongside each other
but i'll be there to help like i love
shopping i'm just saying so i'm here i'm
here for it i'm down for it okay we'll
do it for sure thank you so much love
your energy and i'm so excited for the
journey you're on this is incredible
thank you thank you
you